hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
book six of Aristotle's categories is
devoted to the category of quantity or
the how much or how long or you know
something in terms of number one of thee
or rather two of the things that that
seem to be closely connected that
Aristotle discusses
in the course of his analysis our time
or Chronos and space or topos sometimes
also translated as place now why does he
examine these well because he says that
these are types of quantity there is
something else that I do need to say
right at the start which is that
Aristotle gives a lot more analysis and
discussion to the notions of time and
space in some of his other works and
what he's providing you here is sort of
just a little thumbnail sketch in terms
of quantity not discussing these things
primarily on their own account so if
you're interested in that sort of thing
you want to want to go to some of his
other works like the physics and the
metaphysics but we're not going to do
that here we're only going to worry
about what he actually says in chapter 6
about time and space
so what does Aristotle tell us he says
that both of these are what he calls
continuous quantity so not discrete
quantity like number and that might be a
little bit difficult to wrap your head
around at first because we think of
numbers as actually following in a
sequence so you know and we also think
of the number line as well in
mathematics so that numbers are all
jammed up one on top of the other almost
and touching each other and you know
bleeding over into each other that's not
at all how Aristotle thinks about it but
that is how he thinks about time and
space so what does he have to say says
time is a whole and continuous why
because present past and future are
linked they're connected with each other
and we often ourselves picture this in
you know two complementary ways like you
know the past is back there we think of
it line right usually right and we're
somewhere along the line the past is
back there and the present is right here
and the future is yet to come
and we're like moving into the future or
we could think of the line as like us
staying still and here comes that future
nothing past is receding behind us but
all of these moments exist in some sort
of continuity with each other
that's what Aristotle says at one point
and another point he will say well I'm
not really quite sure about that because
if you think about it strictly speaking
moments of time don't exist except at
that moment of time now that's looking
at it from the point of view of the
present what he's talking about here is
a you're looking at it in a somewhat
different more abstract view but in any
case he views it as continuous so he
says these are all linked with each
other space is also this kind of
quantity why seeing the parts of a solid
themselves occupy so much space and
these parts have a
in comment he says it follows that the
parts of space also which those parts
themselves occupy have exactly the same
common limit or term as the parts of the
solid so he says as with time so is
space then continuous the parts meet at
some common boundaries so that that's
you know there's there's really two key
elements to this notion here as he's
developing it the parts meet at some
sort of limits so if we're thinking
about like this I understand we're have
an object right here but imagine that
we're just talking about the space this
object occupies right this part is
contiguous to this part is contiguous to
this part and so on and so on and so on
so we might say you know in terms of
inches if we want to use that here this
inch this inch this inch this inch this
inch it looks like it's probably six
inches right if I'm measuring remotely
correctly all these parts are contiguous
with each other in in terms of time we
just have that one sort of line in which
the parts are connected with each other
and it's not really a line per se
because that's in space we just have
some sort of you know connection in
terms of space each part is connected
with more parts than just one because
you know we live we exist in a plenum a
three-dimensional plenum so there's
meeting at limits alright these two
parts meet here my wrist is where my
hand and my arm meet and we can get more
and more refined with this sort of thing
you know my each one of my hairs meets
my scalp at the follicle or I know the
follicle is inside but you get the idea
so that's one key thing the parts meet
at at limits the other part is that the
other thing the other feature is that
the parts have position faces in in in
Greek or you know the words to set in
place in relation to each other and as
we mentioned when we're thinking about
time you know what we started out
talking about at the very beginning the
the earlier time
when I was talking about that that
exists in a certain relation to what I'm
doing right now and what will be
happening three minutes from now it's
interesting because you yourself can
represent this to yourself in YouTube by
looking at that time line right below
the video that allows you to say jump
forward three minutes or jump backwards
three minutes right in some cases you
even know when the advertiser is coming
up because there's a little red a little
yellow notch there that shows you that
so that's one way and then there's you
know in in three-dimensional space all
of the parts have position in relation
to each other as well so I get closer to
the camera right I go further away from
the camera
you notice that because of perspective
and that's all about positioning right
so this is continuous quantity this is
these are certain aspects of what it
means to be continuous quantity most
importantly there is some sort of how
much an area a space a length of time
that we can measure out so that's one
key idea another key idea that Aristotle
explores here you notice that Aristotle
is very interested in what has
contraries and what doesn't and how we
can think about contraries contraries
our time antia in greek those are the
things that are opposed to each other
like black and white or good and bad and
any of these sorts of things now
Aristotle says that time doesn't have
contraries right one time is not opposed
to another time and there's nothing else
that you can oppose to a time right so
it doesn't make sense to talk about time
as having contraries but what about
space space does seem to be the sort of
thing that might admit of contraries in
the way that Aristotle is looking at
things why would that be the case well
think about words
that we use in opposition to each other
like above and below those seem to be
contraries don't they they're not
actually contraries though according to
Aristotle at least not contraries in the
same sense as black and white or good
and bad or hot and cold would be to each
other or sweet and bitter even why not
well when we're defining them and he
actually uses the word define their
hoary sky right when we define these
things as contraries we're actually
doing so in reference to something else
so as opposed to contraries that can't
exist in a subject so you know we've got
a we've got for example a book right
alright let's let's not use the book
let's use a piece of chalk piece of
track is cold heat it up and now the
piece of chalk itself has admitted of
change the coldness is gone heat is now
there we can predicate heat of it it has
it has a different contrary that's a
process of change I go from being a good
person to being a bad person that
doesn't happen all at once but over over
sometime right I change it's it's me the
substance or the piece of truck that is
what is allowing the change in this case
above and below is just in reference to
another point of space so to say this
space is above and this space is below
is making reference to something that's
in between another point in space the
center he calls it
so these are not strictly speaking
contrary now he does say something very
interesting as sort of a side remark
when we're defining contraries in a sort
of metaphorical sense we think of them
in spatial terms in terms of distancing
from each other what is furthest from
black/white what is furthest from good
bad what is farthest from hot sweet no
white no cold right there's a greater
distance there and dry what we could use
other things like that as well sweet
bitter in Aristotle's schema of tastes
are the most opposed to each other so we
think of them in essentially
metaphorical terms as distant from each
other so we're thinking in terms of
spatiality but there really are no
contraries in space there's just
position there's just relative position
to each other the other thing that that
he talks about that's that's quite
interesting is this notion that time and
space as quantity in a primary sense
provide us with the frame of reference
for thinking about quantity in in
derivative sense and I talked about this
in another place an action for example
or a process of change is can is
understood and given a kind of number in
terms of the time that that action
requires so you know how long is it how
long is this lecture look at the video I
don't know how long it is yet because I
haven't finished an edited that process
itself would have a certain amount of
time which I'm probably not going to
measure but I'll only know after I get
up in them Wow an hour has passed right
so time is is quantity in a primary
sense and we measure other things with
time likewise space you know if we say
this book is 6 inches by 4 inches which
I'm not quite sure is true but I'm
willing to bet for for the time being by
by an inch and a half right we're using
a certain amount of space as the measure
for this
likewise you know my tie is I don't know
foot and a half long maybe maybe a
little bit longer using space right how
long does it take
to tie my tie the action right how long
does it take me to to undo it
not that long compared to how long it
takes me to actually tie my tie we
measure these things in relation to time
and space so as types of quantity time
and space are incredibly important